So, there's a word that gets thrown
around a lot in online performance
circles. Probably the most common word I
see posted in online groups on the
topic, and that word is undercutting.
Many people I've seen talking about it
agree that it's a scourge. But why does
it happen in the first place? And how
can we stop it from happening? Believe
it or not, the answer might lie with
this year's Nobel Economics Prize
winners. No, really.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And today I'm going to explain
one of the most confounding problems in
the flow arts world with research so
good it actually won a Nobel Prize. But
first up I want to give a shout out to
the friends of the channel. Big thanks
to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests,
Flow Toys, Pyroer Light Toys, and
Ultraoy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible. You can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. So, we're
going to need a couple different pieces
of background here. First up, the
Spheres Rick Spunk Prize in Economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel or
just the Nobel Prize in Economics is a
yearly award given out to economists and
social scientists whose research is
judged to have made the most important
contributions to our understanding of
economics and the broader world. It's
sometimes seen as a prize for the social
sciences in general being as how any
research in psychology, sociology, or
political science will likely trickle
into economics at some point. And this
year, the award was given to three
different individuals. Joel Moir, Phipe
Aan, and Peter Howitt. We're going to
forget about Joel because it's Philipe
and Peter's research that's much more
pertinent. Next, if you have asked any
questions whatsoever about business in
the flow arts, you have had that
question answered by somebody who will
talk about performance because we have a
lot of performers in the flow arts
world. And I guarantee you it's not long
before they start talking about
undercutting. In brief, undercutting is
the practice of lowering the price of
one's goods or services to gain a
competitive advantage in a given market.
And in the context of the flow arts, it
appears most frequently when performers
new to a market price themselves under
their competition, sometimes not
charging for their services at all.
Having a number of actors in a market
that are all charging less for a given
good or service creates downward
pressure on the price of the good and
service in general, and the veterans
have to adjust their pricing to
compensate. and it generates a pretty
big stink because it drives the industry
veterans in a given area absolutely
bananas when they're trying to earn a
stable living through performance. This
of course is not the only context in
which the word appears in the flow arts
world. For years, undercutting was also
a huge problem in the contact po market
when there was a glut of living room
manufacturers setting up Etsy shops. And
of course, it's been a long-standing
problem in the realm of instructor pay
at fire and flow festivals, where eager
flow artists will accept little or no
pay for the opportunity to appear on a
teaching lineup. Of course, lots of
people think of that latter case as an
example of a feature instead of a bug,
including, to my great frustration, many
performers who otherwise complain
incessantly about undercutting in
performance markets, but see
undercutting in teaching lineups as a
form of community building rather than
opportunity loss for a professional
class. Crumble, but that's a topic for
another time. So, why exactly does
undercutting happen in the first place?
To get the most obvious answer out of
the way, a big part of it is that Flow
Arts is overwhelmingly made up of people
who are hobbyists looking to gain
confidence or improve self-image. The
vast majority of whom struggle to assign
value to their services and fear
rejection far more than they fear
poverty. I have talked to a lot, and I
do mean a lot, of up-and-coming
performers who price themselves down,
not out of a deliberate strategy to tank
the local performance market, but
because they view themselves as so
inexperienced as to be unable to charge
the same amount as the seasoned
professionals in the area. In essence,
they say, "I'm not as good as this other
performer in my area, so I have to
charge less." Of course, what they fail
to realize is that by flooding the
market with cheap or free options, they
are changing the perception of value
within that market. Potential clients
may look at two different performers
charging vastly different rates and
wonder why the discrepancy in price when
on the surface the services look very,
very similar. It does also have to be
said that many people simply want to be
seen and share their spinning and lack a
good outlet to do so. Given that the
only opportunities to present their work
in their area may be as a performer, it
forces them to compete with the seasoned
professionals in a way that neither
party ultimately benefits from. It's
been suggested many times that what's
needed is ultimately something like a
union or trade guild that sets standards
of pay, safety, and conduct while also
providing mentorship to neopight flow
artists looking for entry into this
particular world. Some of these efforts
have gained limited traction, but
ultimately tend to either fall apart in
the long run or never get off the launch
pad. See, many of us see playing with
fire as not just an essential part of
our art, but also a goal to be
constantly striving for. Something that
is so taboo and forbidden that in many
municipalities, it's illegal unless
performed under the right conditions. In
other words, people who want to break
rules and avoid oversight are kind of
baked into the appeal of our art form
from the get-go. Convincing them to join
a professional organization kind of
misses the point of the basic appeal of
doing this in the first place for many.
Personally, I also look at this tension
between the pros and the neopights and
can't help but notice that there might
be an opportunity here. Namely, if there
are so many people willing to either
spin for free or pay for the privilege
of doing so, a savvy young entrepreneur
might just find an opportunity to charge
new flow artists for the opportunity to
show off their work and charge an
audience to view such an event and make
money on both sides of the equation. But
that too is likely a conversation for
another time. And the reason for that is
that there are solutions outlined in the
research of masters Aen and Howitt.
admit it, you totally forgot about them
already that I think could be helpful to
us in addressing these questions because
likely without ever seeing a single flow
artist perform, they already seem to
understand the marketplace quite well.
There's a great explainer on this year's
Nobel Prize winners in economics that
I'll link to down in the description,
but there's a couple sections in
particular that I want to highlight.
Here they are. What their model showed
was that there was an inverted U curve
of economic innovation depending on how
competitive the market was. If the
market is just insanely cutthroat with
every company stealing every other
company's designs and ideas and
relentlessly undercutting one another
all the time, that would be good for
consumers [music] for a little while.
However, nobody would be willing to
innovate because there would be no
profit motive to do [music] so. Now,
they weren't describing the flow arts
world specifically, but I got to admit
it sounds pretty familiar. Right now,
the flow arts market is one of those
insanely cutthroat ones. People steal
ideas from each other all the time and
there's so little money to be made
overall that it hinders innovation and
as the researchers found it means a
market that is good for consumers in the
short term. The consumers in this case
being the clientele for performances who
are getting a great deal on that product
right now. So if Agian and Howit are
able to describe a problem in the flow
arts without seeing it directly, does
that mean they can also see a solution?
Well, maybe. Here's what they had to say
about fixing these sorts of markets. The
solution to maximizing innovation was to
create economic policies that made a
little bit of market dominance possible
through protecting intellectual
property, but also avoided too much
dominance through trust busting and
limiting how long IP would be protected
for. So, it's here that things get a
little sticky because what exactly is
the intellectual property in question?
Is it a performance convention, a unique
prop, or an act? Maybe. I've seen some
performers who come up with really
unique gimmicks that require a load of
research and development and that could
conceivably give them an edge in a
creative performance market. And I've
seen others create work that exists in a
unique space as a narrative or
structured performance that only they
have the personnel and staging to
present. The other challenge is that
defending intellectual property is an
expensive proposition. It's not a big
deal for a big tech company, but for an
individual performer struggling to make
rent, hiring a lawyer to help them out
is a daunting proposition. And of
[clears throat] course, the words
intellectual property will make a
certain segment of the flow arts world
very uncomfortable given the
anti-corporate open-source values that
are frequently promoted within it. So,
what do we do? The short answer is that
I don't have a solution. But I do think
it's helpful to use tools like this to
identify both what the problems are and
where they come from. Flow arts
performance is a marketplace that is
vulnerable to undercutting precisely
because there is little if any
intellectual property to protect there
performers can seem largely
undifferentiated to people looking to
hire entertainers and this discourages
innovation because there simply isn't
enough money to be made to justify
investments of time and energy. Of
course, many people will likely argue
that the flow arts is innovating
constantly, but I think they're viewing
it through a lens that is intercommunal
rather than intracommunal.
That is people come up with new tricks
all the time. But those innovations make
very little difference in booking gigs.
So the challenge may be to find not only
things that can be protected as a form
of intellectual property, but also a
mechanism by which that very thing can
happen. And that is a whole challenge in
and of itself. But who knows, maybe
you're up for the challenge. Well, that
was a fun intellectual exercise. If you
got anything out of this video, please
make sure to like, share, and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow.
[music]
This video would not have been possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I'd love to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
up on screen right now. Thank you all so
much for your very generous support. If
you would like to get your name in the
credits or access to a host of other
rewards, you can sign up for my Patreon
over at patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll leave a link down in the comments
as well as up in the cards. Please help
me out in my mission of bringing po
spinning and flowarts to the whole wide
world. Thank you in advance. If you'd
like to check out some other video
essays I've done on the flow arts and
economics, I'll link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up on screen. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.